it's to a man
[Music]
it's an exciting moment going to adesso
which is roughly 11 hours of me
odessa ukraine
[Music]
you
so first impressions were these wide
beautiful boulevards with trees so the
trees were just creating this canopy of
shade as we drove into the center of the
city
everything here feels a little bit more
grand you can feel that it was once a
very a very important place and so you
feel it in the architecture you feel it
in the way the city was laid out and I
was told it's actually a lot of French
and Italians with the architects behind
a lot of this construction a lot of cool
detail in the buildings so there was you
know ivy and grapevines growing up the
buildings
what's a Mediterranean feel in a way but
with a Ukranian twist the challenge
always is
finding some cool locals because it's
one thing for me to talk about the place
when I don't know much about it or rip
off some basic historical facts it's
another thing to find cool people that
help me bring out to this place to the
camera here with Dennis and Dennis you
said you're gonna show me one of the
coolest things in the city yes we're
going to come up a little bit
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you think this thing gets regularly
maintained quite a culture experience
this is from Soviet times right yeah
we're going right into the Black Sea
what are the big surprises with the
Black Sea is it's not black and okay
people in this part of the world
obviously know that from what I've seen
it's gone sometimes like a deep blue or
turquoise color to it it's set up for
this beach culture and this whole party
vibe on the beach and there's this
massive walkway and it's it's very open
and expansive
[Music]
the cat's everywhere here it's cat
culture but what were you saying this so
there are a lot of cats here because why
because back in the day they brought
cats here to fight rats that were coming
here from the ships okay check this out
man okay yeah I see cats and I see a
very cool courtyard well and it smells
like cat it's a lot yeah actually I
noticed is this normal
yeah like a courtyard like this typical
super typical do you know why do you
know why it was built like this just to
have this peaceful internal area so long
history of living together communication
super quiet here doesn't that box but it
gets really still you can you can hear
people washing dish
someone's hanging their clothes to dry
and in the evening you can hear people
chatting from the windows even smell the
fish is being fried
there's a lot of color here so I see
color in the buildings I see color in
the people people dress with more color
I feel it's a bit more animated it has a
bit more of that Mediterranean feel that
it you know that say Italian style where
it's a little more expressive so I mean
you company in outwardly emotional the
life is on the streets it's at a pace
much much slower than the capital Keith
it's very chill here he's very new very
melodically and it's one of those places
you can just you know envelop yourself
and like go into the streets and really
get a lot of pleasure just walking these
long beautiful boulevards
[Music]
it's a port city and it's its history
you know at one time it was a very big
port and it was very cosmopolitan so how
does that air about it port cities
always have that like true port cities
always have that feel of an adventure in
them are you creating captain's on the
boats here get ten thousand a month you
think yeah I know so you can like make
sixty grand a year for anymore if you
don't have a family and you just you
know you want to spend twelve months a
year
MCs it's a long way to become a captain
heinous kind of wild west of Europe
because it's kind of a European country
but you got like barkings very bad
like the walls don't really work but you
got so much freedom here especially if
you're the preneur yeah like the stuff
is not that regulated that much you can
make the first money here very easy but
you got to deal with corruption and
stuff I feel like a strong juxtaposition
beteen all the new so you can see it
definitely in the architecture the a lot
of these buildings are falling apart a
bit a lot need to be restored and then
you see these new businesses that are
very modern looking and they could be in
the same building like one building can
be you know it can be falling apart at
the top and look condemned and then the
bottom is this brand new business that's
well lit and well designed cobblestones
way under this
and most of this is actually covers a
couple
but most of the cobblestone is under the
asphalt for some reason but this
cobblestone is super famous it's
actually Italian they look like Naples
looks like in Naples it's actually built
out of the shell rock this is shell rock
it was made out of shells by millions of
years and at the sea so when they
started to build the city it was the
easiest way to just dig underground and
get out the shell rock and build the
city so now we have a huge huge lane of
catacombs under the city that you can
explore it's like the biggest mirror you
can tell the city had its best days
behind it I don't know when that was
sometime in the nineteenth century I
believe is when it was like that it's
the most booming time so it's not at its
height right now but you see this young
energy sort of like poking thrill it
seems like there's some sort of
Renaissance going on and there are
people creating here and you can feel
that on the streets it's nice to see
that the the city is changing the people
their mentality is also changing and
also anything about that like what what
do you see right now like around this
park pretty much made by a younger
generation right younger generation
didn't want to disturb you
this new mentality and they see how it's
I was doing positive things and these
cops are coming out of so they corrupt
or know these guys they're in the
Academy so they're not corrupt yet
faith I don't think a lot of people have
enough faith that it's possible I mean
there's still some kind of like the
stereotypical believe that there's no
future Ukraine is falling apart we need
to move to the United States for example
right and they don't know much about it
and they they didn't know a lot about
space maybe your life's better than
maybe it's not
yeah it's baby you're not going to need
there's one thing for sure first certain
you're not gonna meet Brad Pitt on
Hollywood Boulevard like so many people
think you're like it's just like the
movies yeah when this whole political
situation happens with Russia and when
there was when after a war people here
like the whole mentality the whole
psychology people kind of got shook it
up and he the good amount of people who
had some kind of like a awakening moment
inside of them and and that's where I
see the change people I see their this
in their eyes and I'm very proud of it
there's a there's a saying tough times
cray strong people strong people create
good times good times create weak people
with people creating four times at night
this gets busy right yes it gets busy on
the weekends the big busy overnight or
when the weather is good every night
here there's a movie theater uh-huh like
an open sky movie theater cool question
very big portion is yes pretty big
beautiful yeah alive Oh little promotion
[Music]
well Edessa was influenced a lot by
jewish culture still a lot of people a
lot of people come from these a lot of
people from odessa actually migrated to
New York right small Odessa in New York
I've only been here a couple days so the
food I've tasted has been fantastic a
lot of seafood garlic parsley thyme
chard and vegetables I love that like
the charred vegetables that have been
grilled and they have that black char on
them so Serge you were telling me what
about this place this place was a movie
theater back in the beginning of 20th
century
then it was Church then it was a rock
club and now it's a City Football Club
[Music]
just happen there bro
we went through a secret passage
underground passage from the city food
market into the Georgian capital I
really like those little secret passages
amazing you can go inside
very interesting in Odessa when you
round a corner near University and then
all the Senate turns very Asian very
Indian very middle-eastern 80% probably
in medical university are not trained
use as most people from Arab countries
or why because the education the medical
education is super cool our Harvard and
it's protein so we produce doctors for
third countries so they can go back and
help people interesting imbalance where
you see you know such opulence and then
you see decay and people just getting by
usually when you have such a range of
economic disparity there's crime in the
mix and I don't feel it's dangerous here
on the streets
I really don't not at once walking
around at night or whenever have I ever
felt like oh this is a sketchy place
someone's gonna come at me with a knife
you know in a dark alley I'm sure it
happens but it really overall and I've
been told it's it's a safe it's a safe
city to be in
[Music]
pretty rad appreciate your your wisdom
your cool words and look you guys tell
the story the people I run into and it's
like I've ran into some very cool people
that have just come out of nowhere and
like told their stories or just destroy
their country and it's a pretty sweet
man it's special it's a special place
it's bit of the Mediterranean and a bit
of Slavic culture of mixed in one pot
it's all over the place to be honest
which is cool that's what makes it
interesting I like places like this all
right that's that's my story
[Music]